our eye on earth series a major report
just out from the UN focuses on the key
role of our food and land use in
fighting climate change scientists
outlined the results of the two-year
study this morning in Switzerland the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change says agriculture forestry and
other land uses produce nearly half of
the world's methane emissions
that's a greenhouse gas that also comes
from cows Adriana Diaz is on a cattle
ranch in Greeley Kansas Adriana what are
Ranchers they're telling you well
Anthony a good morning ranchers say it's
not efficient to eat less meat as a way
to fight climate change to give you some
context one study says that going vegan
for a year will reduce your carbon
footprint by half as much as avoiding a
single flight to Europe still today's
report says that changing your diet can
help fight global warming though many
ranchers think the cow kamek the cow
climate change connection is overblown
rancher brandy buzzards says the cattle
she raises for beef
are part of the solution to climate
change not the problem and cattle graze
on grass pastures they are actually
improving the grass and and what they're
grazing on we are doing everything we
can to improve our environmental
footprint that footprint according to
today's report contributes to the 44% of
methane emissions that come from
agriculture forestry and human land use
according to the authors there has been
a major growth in emissions from managed
pastures due to increased manure
deposition that's right
cow manure admits methane which can also
come from cow burps and yes cow
flatulence electricity generation and
transportation like car emissions make
up the majority of US produced
greenhouse gases but cows account for
2.6 percent so I think that we can make
more impactful changes in our lives
through recycling or walking to work or
using public transportation than we can
by actually changing what we eat because
it will have such a minimal impact but
changing what we eat is what the report
suggests it argues in part that eating
more plant-based foods and sustainably
produced meats can change land-use and
mitigate climate change
the purpose of this report is to say
that just doing transportation and
electricity isn't enough we need to also
think about our land use and we need to
think about agriculture that's why some
dairy farms like this one in California
are trapping methane from manure under
tarps and converting it to fuel for
trucks at UC Davis scientists are using
the equivalent of a cow breathalyzer to
measure how different feed affects
manure outputs UC Davis professor Frank
MIT Lerner studies livestock and air
quality he and the new report one
Americans to also focus on the emissions
wasted on food they don't consume 40
percent of all food produced in this
country goes to waste and you know who
the main culprit is you and I so if
you're really concerned about your
personal environmental footprint around
food well waste less some ranchers we
spoke to say they do believe in climate
change and they're trying to combat it
but they think the earth is being
impacted by changing weather patterns
not global warming still today's report
says that temperatures over land have
increased nearly three degrees
Fahrenheit compared to pre-industrial
levels Dana
Adriana certainly seeing that it's not
just one thing that may be enough thank
you